(gentle music)
- Today is the two year anniversary
of my failed suicide attempt.
- This is hard.
For the last couple years,
I have been in a hole
that seems unsurmountable
and though I may not show it,
it is slowly engulfing me.
- After a decade in the
military, I figure out,
it's a joke and I don't want
to be a part about it anymore.
We good, all right.
- My secret is not so well
kept as there's other people
in my predicament, I
served 12 years in prison,
and been a victim of
the mental health system
not being effective
enough in helping people,
but aside from that, all
systems go, living life at 100.
Why so serious?
- I genuinely believe in my
heart that my mom's love for me
is completely conditional
on whether or not I become
successful in my career or in
my school and that if I don't
do well I feel like she won't
love me and she won't care
about me and to be honest,
she said somethings
and she's done somethings where
I've really needed her help
and she definitely wasn't there for me.
So I probably I have, my
secret is I have deep seeded
trust issues against my mom,
but even though I tell her
I love her everyday.
- I have been in love with my
best friend, who is a female
for the past four years and
nobody will ever know that
'cause I'm not ready for
anybody to know that.
- My secret is,
food is a very big challenge for me.
I'm struggling with it
along with body image.
- So I'm 49 years old
and my secret is that
I struggle with vanity and
so as a 49 year old woman
who's definitely not getting
younger, I deal with aging,
or actually, I don't deal
with it at all and it actually
holds me back.
When you've grown up your
whole life with the expectation
of always looking good and
being in shape and being thin
and being the best that you
can be, when beauty fades
one day they don't tell you
that, that beauty fades,
to my surprise, I am
gonna turn 50 this year
and my beauty is fading and, sorry,
so I have let the aging
hold me back from so many
things in just the last
probably five years.
I threw out all my bathing
suits, most of my shorts,
basically I stopped really
wanting to socialize
because I look older, I've
gained weight, and I didn't think
that I would be accepted anymore
because my beauty has faded
and that kind of, it kind of
changed one day when I was
hanging out with my 16 year old daughter,
her and her friends.
It was just the simplest
words that she said to me,
but it's really changed me
in the past couple weeks
and she just looked at me,
'cause I had explained to her
that I don't wear bathing
suits and I just don't feel
beautiful anymore
because I'm getting older
and she just looked at me
and she said embrace it.
There's nothing you can do
about it so just embrace it.
You're beautiful the way that
you are and so I just wanna
get that out to anybody
that's struggling with that,
just get rid of that vanity,
get rid of that insecurity
and just embrace who
you are, those changes.
Thank you.
- I come from a conservative
household and really religious
and I've grown up in
that faith, but recently,
since I've moved out, I just
wish my parents and my friends,
who are also religious,
could realize that I'm trying
to find a relationship
with my faith on my own
and that doesn't mean that
I will follow all the rules,
so I will follow what
I can but it's my life
and my connection with faith
that I'm trying to figure out
on my own and I wish they
would just let me do that
without criticizing me
and telling me what to do.
- When I was little I used
to lie and make up stories
about who my biological father
actually was because I was
ashamed of who he is.
- My dad isn't really in
my life and I always joke
about how that's fun because
it's fun to be a girl
with daddy issues.
I really wish I made more
of an effort to contact him,
'cause I'm sure he wants to
talk to me, so that's my secret.
- When my brother died, I
wanted to die with him too.
- I self harmed for the first
time yesterday since 8th grade
and the only thing that's
keeping me going is imagining
retiring in New Zealand or
Austria or somewhere else,
but I think it turned out okay.
- I guess my secret is I'm very
selfish and a lot of people
that meet me don't think
I am, but it's something
that I struggle with everyday
and I try to change it.
- My secret is that after being single
for two and a half years I'm
not really sure that I want to
have sex with anyone for a
while because I just don't
want to get intimate with
anyone, it's just too
much of a pain in my ass and
I don't have a lot of trust
for people at this point anymore.
- When I was poor, I used
to steal from groceries.
Whenever the opportunity presented itself.
I wasn't an aggressive
thief, it was more like,
oh I left the water jug at
the bottom of the grocery cart
and they didn't notice and
I didn't tell them about it.
I did not, if anything,
just more embarrassed
that I was poor.
I will remain anonymous.
- I find all people
attractive and I don't think
that love should be confined.
- So I have quarantined
myself away from everybody
except strangers on dating apps.
- When I was five years
old, my mother called
the fire department 'cause we
had a television that exploded
and she never knew this, but I
actually urinated in the back
of the TV to see what would happen.
What possessed me to
do that I do not know.
- So about a year ago, (laughing)
I went to a party with me and
my friends and we all decided
how funny it would be
if I got an ass tattoo.
I was like what should
I get, and as my friend
was very drunk, and if you
would like to see the tattoo
I can. (laughing)
And so, he had me bent
over a hot tub and he kept
poking my ass with a
sticking poke to get a tattoo
that says shit happens on my butt.
And that's all.
- I should probably have
a sip of this first.
Because my secret is that
there's a little bit of tequila
in this here seltzer.
- He looks sexier with new clothes.
(laughing)
- [Interviewer] Oh that's perfect.
- I didn't hear what you said.
- I said you look sexier with new clothes.
(laughing)
(gentle music)
- Hey guys Thoraya here,
just wanna let you guys know
that to be safe, I do
have a mark on the ground
so people are far enough from
the mic, not to touch it.
Also, after every single
person goes, I make sure
to clean the mic.
I love you guys.
I hope you're staying safe.
Make sure to subscribe if you
want, if not, it's all good,
no hard feelings, all right, bye.